Tu m'avais dit 16h il est 18h30.
J'ai prolongé parce qu'il s'éclatait.
- Ce soir pas de dépassement.
- Non grave, je coupe tout à 4h.
- 1 heure.
- 3 heures.
- T'es viré.
- Okay ! Une heure c'est très bien.
Ça se passe bien ?
Sam ? Tu me reconnais pas c'est ça ?
Ah mais oui, oui oui ! Christine !
- Christine de Berlin.
- De Londres.
De Londres, voila c'est ça, of course.
C'est cool de te voir avec ton bébé.
C'est ta fille.
- Est ce que tu la connais cette meuf ?
- Bon on a vaguement couché ensemble.
Mais franchement pas assez pour dire :
"Bah tchao, voila c'est ta fille, salut !"
Elle se barre là, non ?
Christine !
T'as oublié tes affaires !
Ce qui se passe c'est que je veux juste rendre un enfant comme c'est pas à moi.
- Christine !
- Carte d'embarquement et passeport.
- Ma copine elle a oublié sa fille.
Ah mais donc tu connais qu'une phrase toi.
J'ai un bébé sur les bras. Je trouve pas sa mère.
J'ai tout perdu, mon porte-feuille.
J'ai plus de couches et il pleut. Vous parlez français ?
- Ah ouais ça m'arrive ouais.
- Ah vous allez me sauver la vie !
Avec plaisir !
On est pas un peu près là ?
C'est pas faux.
Si vous changez d'avis, y'a mes coordonnées pros,
et ça c'est perso.
*bébé qui pleure*
Papa.
Tu l'as dit !
Avez vous la moindre idée des conséquences de votre éducation sur Gloria ?
- Aie !
- Oh pardon !
La semaine dernière, elle n'est pas venue du tout.
Ah bon ? Même pas le lundi ?
Papa ! Maman elle m'a envoyé un mail !
T'arrêtes d'envoyer des faux mails,
et tu dis la vérité à ta fille.
Un matin elle va se rendre compte que tu lui mens depuis des années.
Et ça crois moi ça ça va réellement la rendre malheureuse.
Je sais.
Oh putain !
Maman !
Ça a duré huit ans !
Tu sais ce que c'est huit ans ?!
C'est une éternité.
Faut qu'elle rentre à la maison et que tout soit comme avant.
Sam ça peut pas être exactement comme avant
Si elle est venue pour foutre la merde dans la famille c'est pas la peine.
J'ai pas envie de la rendre malheureuse tu peux entendre ça ?
Gloria est arrivée dans ma vie du jour au lendemain.
J'étais pas prêt.
Mais j'ai fait du mieux que j'ai pu.
Je te laisserai plus jamais.
Je te le promets.
Elle va revenir.
Laisse lui juste un peu de temps.
Du temps, j'en ai pas.